la unión ciclista internacional acaba de
anunciar la descalificación del ciclista
colombiano nairo quintana del tour de
francia de este año pero fue sexto en la
clasificación general de esta división
dando al equipo francés parque santrich
la mejor clasificación en la historia de
la ronda gala desde el comunicado de la
uci en pantalla la unión ciclista
internacional anunció que el ciclista
colombiano nairo alexander quintana
rojas ha sido sancionado por una
infracción de la prohibición del uso de
tramadol en competencia establecida en
el reglamento médico de la uci con el
objetivo de proteger la seguridad y la
salud de los ciclistas a la luz de los
efectos secundarios de la sustancia
aclara la uci que esto no supone una
violación del reglamento antidopaje y
que hacer su primera falta a nairo puede
seguir en competencia recordemos que
nadie tiene previsto correr la vuelta a
españa que comienza ya a pasado mañana
comienza ya este viernes en lo que se
refiere al tramado la uci prohíbe el
consumo de esa sustancia sin competencia
argumentando que tiene riesgo de
dependencia y efectos secundarios como
mareo o perdiz atención justamente ayer
nairo había renovado con su equipo la
arc ya sanz y hasta el 2025 poniendo fin
a muchos rumores se hablaba de una
prolongación a solamente hay un año y
finalmente va a ser hasta el 2025 él
tiene 32 años ya el equipo confía en él
están trabajando bien y justamente llega
esta noticia y con esta noticia juan le
preguntó que dicen desde el entorno en
aire raúl desde el entorno negro dicen
que se trata de un error y que van a
hacer toda la defensa posible porque la
uci en su comunicado también le da ahora
nairo 10 días de defensa ante el
tribunal de arbitraje deportivo por
parte de la que asan signo ha habido una
reacción todavía pero desde su equipo de
comunicaciones nos explican que están
trabajando ya demasiado comunicado más
completo para explicar y que tanto su
equipo de médicos como de abogados están
trabajando en su defensa claro porque
además esto le afecta digamos su
reputación no sea de alguna manera el
buen nombre no claro y sobre todo una
clasificación muy buena que acaba de
conseguir ese sexto lugar en el tour de
francia además es una clasificación que
le da puntos importantes a su equipo
para con el objetivo de ser un equipo de
ball tour de la máxima categoría del
ciclismo esto es un revés enorme para la
buena temporada que ha hecho a nairo
quintana